seven months ago eight months ago
bernie sanders berated elon musk
just a bunch of things he's making too
much money because i think
uh elon musk had uh gotten what uh
2.4 billion dollars of subsidies for
tesla
and he got 5.6 million dollars of
subsidies for spacex
and they're going back and forth there
was a few and elon really didn't say
much but
sanders pretty much trashed them right
this last week it got a little bit ugly
where they were going back and forth on
twitter if you want to bring this up
bernie sanders started off by sending
this tweet he said
we are in a moment in american history
where two guys elon musk and jeff bezos
own more wealth
than the bottom 40 of people in this
country that level of greed and
inequality is not only immoral it's
unsustainable
okay that's his first tweet then you
have elon musk that responds saying i am
accumulating resources to help make
life multi-planetary and extend the
light
of consciousness to the stars sanders
responds
space travel is an exciting idea but
right now we need to focus on earth and
create a progressive tax system
so that children don't go hungry people
are not homeless and all americans have
health care
the level of inequality in america is
obscene and a
threat to our democracy thoughts well
he's a quack i mean i look at the words
he is who
qualified bernie yeah progressive
tax system okay three words there so
there's no homelessness
we have a progressive tax system in
california
have you seen the homelessness there
there's a progressive
tax system in seattle in the state of
washington homeless is completely out of
control there
you know bernie has a brand that he has
to sell and he's an
anti-capitalist guy so he's got two
people square in his crosshairs
it's musk and it's bezos and it's
perfect for him
um he can rail on them constantly yeah
but here's my problem
is it greed i mean it's not like they're
stealing money it's not like he's an
oligarch
or ogler or whatever the word is in
russia where you're giving an
industry essentially and then you just
steal all the money these guys have
started a business from scratch
essentially invested everything they had
and done very very well for themselves i
i'm curious to see if bernie sanders
ever orders anything on amazon
do you think he doesn't just because he
can't allow himself to
to not support and do you think jeff
bezos has gone
and pull up his profile to see what kind
of things bernie sanders orders on
amazon can you imagine
hey mary can you pull up bernie sanders
uh profile on vermont and tell us what
he orders you know i guarantee you
he doesn't drop it right he doesn't
drive a tesla i know that do you know
what car bernie sanders drives
is it the a-i which one is it the audi
no i think he used to have one of those
now he drives the subaru forester
is that is that still a thing i can
actually see him in a super i think i
think that is more fitting for him to be
aligned with his message than it is the
yeah out the audi here here's my final
thought on this and
this is completely unproductive
what he's doing with this twitter feud
it keeps his brand alive
because he does have a brand all right
this is him
okay we all know his background here's a
better idea
why don't you go spend some time with
these guys and mind their brain a little
bit instead of getting trying to get all
their money
i mean they solve every other damn
problem in this country i mean compare
the
government's united states postal
service with amazon
who's a little bit more efficient when
it comes to delivering products okay
maybe there's something to learn from
bezos
or you know looks like we're going to
solve the high-speed
internet problem for the whole world
thanks to elon musk
treat these guys as your allies they're
brilliant
learn from them tap their resources in
their mind and figure out a way to help
the entire country
instead of just trying to make a money
grab constantly adam
yeah you know actually i have some
pretty strong opinions on the on this
topic so
just for a second let's pretend that we
don't know either of their names
so bernie is b and elon's e we don't
know
one guy's like look we got some major
freaking issues here
on earth in america wealth inequality
whether you're on either side of the
aisle is a real thing you know
billionaires are getting wealthier
uh you talking about um united
healthcare
uh universal healthcare education a
living wage on a minimum minimum minimum
wage
infrastructure fossil fuels clean energy
and he's just kind of you know that's
what
quote unquote person b is talking about
and then the other person is like yeah
but mars bro
mars and he's like what dude you're
talking about mars like
let's focus on we got major problems we
got a pandemic going on right here
uh can we just focus on earth for a
second and he's just like listen man
mars so it's funny because i do respect
elon musk
you know i'm not a fan boy or anything
like that but like the guy she's curious
to know where you're going
with this go ahead okay the guy's a
beast yeah the point is it's so easy to
be like bernie is a quack
bernie's a socialist he's an idiot one
thing i know about bernie
one thing i know about bernie yeah
whether you agree with him politically
or
disagree with him politically the guy
clearly cares
clearly cares he he empathizes with what
the hell the
is plaguing our country whether you
believe with his tax premise or whether
you believe in
socialism or not the guy cares you think
he cares like the way you think he cares
i think how where are you going with
that like you mean you think it's all an
act
you know how i think he cares here's how
i think he cares do you remember the
movie uh what was that movie paul
tom cruise catherine zeta-jones tom
cruise is a star
and he's performing and catherine
zeta-jones is that rock of ages
you know the apollo she's like the local
politician
what is the name of that movie who if
you remember this movie comment below
if it's like a rock of ages he's a rock
star
tom cruise is that the movie yeah
you have never you've never seen that
okay let me see what the name of it is
anyways in that movie
in that movie what's the premise of the
story do you remember that
okay the premise of that story it's a uh
is it tom cruise
uh the premise of that movie um i mean i
i have to figure out exactly what it is
is it this one
okay anyways the premise of that movie
is the following so catherine zeta jones
keeps coming and screaming and i cannot
believe you're doing this you know this
person is bad for the community
he's it's not rock of ages something
else he's terrible for the community
you know he's he's turning our kids into
you know
rock stars and our kids are now smoking
weed and she keeps doing this
and showing up over and over and over
and over
and over again right and eventually i
was like what the hell is wrong with
this woman what do you have against tom
cruise
tom cruise in the movie every time he
performed
this would keep come up every single
time this he performed rock of ages
every time he would perform this would
come up eventually
at the end of the movie i'm ruining it
for everybody who hasn't seen it
he's performing she shows up
he leaves the stage spots are on the
other side of the rail
walks across goes up to her
kisses her and walks off and she just
knees buckle and what happened she fell
in love with them
years ago he didn't end up being with
her he left her broke her heart for her
entire
life she flipped against him and she
used to be one of those groupies that
was crazy about him right
i think bernie's cat catherine zeta
jones i don't i i'm in love with elon no
i think someone
in his life offended him so bad
that he's made it a mission to get after
all these rich people
whether it's a rich uncle whether it's a
rich dad
whether it's a rich friend whether it's
an ex's rich dad that you know he just
didn't like bernie
somebody there offended this guy because
if you look at bernie
can you go to young bernie sanders i
wonder what he looks like what does a
young bernie sanders look like in his
20s
you know young bernie sanders click
there go to images
young bernie sanders okay i mean you can
you can tell this guy was a
uh yeah he he was an interesting guy but
just looking at what this guy looks like
he he's like a young
rudy giuliani okay
you have to be here to kind of know what
that means but the moral of the stories
i think someone offended him
and he got upset and he's doing what
he's got he's got you're basically
saying he's got some
deep rooted oh buddy it's so deep none
of us know about the guy got married in
soviet union he went to soviet union for
his
honeymoon i mean somebody got a hold of
this guy very very early
were you going to make another point
with this where the other guys are
saying space and this guy said
i mean that's just sort of the
overarching theme here i mean all you
have
look one thing this is actually pretty
interesting so
elon musk as much as he's a capitalist
you know a lot of his wealth comes from
this corporate welfare from these uh
government subsidies he's got five
billion in subsidies so
you know just using bernie's words he
says what a hypocrite
elon musk has received billions in
corporate welfare from u.s taxpayers
now he wants to stop 30 million
americans who lost jobs from receiving
600 bucks a week in unemployment while
his wealth has gone up 50 billion
so this was um back in july
most more recently um
every time elon musk pokes fun at
government assistance for the 99
remember he would be worth nothing
without the 5 billion dollars in
corporate welfare
elon musk loves corporate socialism for
himself and then
rugged capitalism for everyone else so
he does have a point there okay elon
musk does get
billions and billions of corporate
subsidies there's a very easy argument
for that there's the argument for that
so many years ago i asked the following
question i said okay
so say you raise taxes from 30 to 40
percent take whatever each percent is
right now by the way fy if you're
listening to this let me tell you
what announcement was just made that i
think everybody needs to know
uh if you have are having any kind of
capital gains
anything going on with major tax event
make sure it happens in 2021
not in 2022 because 2022 get ready to
force
taxes to skyrocket in ways you've never
seen before
my prediction i could be wrong i'm just
telling you 2022 2023
and it's not going to change so 2024
2025 probably 2025
is when the taxes are going to go back
to normal 2022
taxes are going to the roof let me give
you a couple hints on why
this could potentially happen so number
one
uh there's an article that came out this
morning with
morning brew okay and they talk about
how the wealthiest one percent of u.s
households failed to disclose 21
of their income according to a new study
done by who
irs researchers make sense on who would
do
that research the top one percent is
failing to disclose 21
their income okay so what do they do
some of these incomes are automatically
reported to irs but other income stream
can slip by the agency's auditors
who sophisticated strategies including
with sophisticated inc
strategies including what which helped
the top one percent of it offshore
accounts
pass-through businesses llc they want to
target
llc's llcs for years have been what
pass-through businesses which means what
it's a partnership popular with family
firms investment funds real estate
businesses
they're perfectly legal but since their
income isn't taxed at the corporate rate
it's easier to hide and some pilot some
politicians want to raise taxes on
llc catastrophic because that's small
businesses that are doing what they're
doing
these are not billionaires it's a small
llc that we're talking about right
but watch what it ends up with
enforcement
isn't also what it used to be okay audit
rates have slipped over the last decade
as the irs lost 15 000 staffers
the agency commissioner charles reddick
brace for impact
asked congress for more funds arguing
for every one dollar spent
on enforcement the returns are five to
seven
dollars so it means we're gonna go
auditing
more people collecting unpaid income
taxes from the one percent could bring
175 billion
dollars into the treasury annually
that's the study now when you read this
what do you say
there's two ways you can read this
article one is what uh okay yeah let's
go find this money from these rich
people
and the other one is what if there's any
job you don't want to increase
it's what auditors it's what you don't
want we've been i mean i've been audited
every single year i'm at a different
place i'm constantly going through not
fun
i spend a few hundred thousand dollars i
have to do that because of what i go
through totally get it
where we are i'm not disputing it i
totally understand what they
there's a there's a need for their job
but if they're going in this direction
and the sale is what for every dollar
you spent we make what
five to seven dollars now if the other
side
if the congress the the is being sold
this concept by the agency commissioner
charles reddick
which is controlled by who right now the
left buys buys into this and says yeah
that makes sense
they get a bunch of auditors what are
they preparing for they're going to
raise taxes next year it's going to be
announced this year and how it's going
to be
it'll be into effect 1-1 2022.
the people that are the people that
backed up this administration are
telling them whatever you're going to do
don't do it this year let me make my
sales this year
so i can be okay but then start it next
year if you need to because if they
don't
then in the midterms they're going to
get destroyed because they didn't keep
their commitment of raising taxes
because that was one of the things biden
campaign and when biden was going out he
was saying what we're gonna raise taxes
we're raising taxes we're raising taxes
and they said four hundred thousand
dollars
now it's family households above four
hundred thousand dollars
which means it's really what 200 000 if
you're making 200
000 or higher you're most likely going
to increase your taxes corporate taxes
going up we talked about this last week
this is the point i want to make it make
you with uh elon musk and bernie sanders
ten years ago nine years ago i did a
video um
uh i did something having to do with
taxes but this is the question that i
asked
say you got a billion dollars okay a
billion dollars you have to choose
between two people getting this billion
dollars and the goal is to turn this
billion dollars into 10 billion dollars
that's the goal you're investing a
billion dollars to turn it into 10
billion dollars
and create more jobs who do you trust
more to take that billion dollars
to turn it into 10 billion versus a
billion dollars that's going to be
wasted and nothing happens to them
do you trust putting it into the hands
of an entrepreneur or an innovator like
an elon musk
or do you trust putting it in the hands
of a government guy who do you trust
if those are the two options i'm going
with what other options do we have
giving it to the people ubi or something
okay then let's ask that question if you
give it to the people so you got three
options now
you give it to an innovator you give it
to the people you give it to the
government
who duplicates that money the most and
creates the most commerce
commerce who creates the most commerce
creates the most
common commerce jobs economy oh jobs or
commerce
it's the same thing the more business
there is the more employees you need
elon musk
will do the best with jobs perfect
commerce if you're giving
people thousands of dollars they'll go
spend it and do what's best for their
families oh actually that's not how it
works the more money you give to the
people
the more you get their level of
intensity to lower to rely on what
to rely on the government so if you give
it directly to the people
the people are going to keep coming back
to the government it's like starting
allowance too early with high money
you're now expected to be given higher
allowances that's just the expectation
they're going to keep coming back to you
so we know the highest return is going
to be where
in an elon musk type of a person small
and i'm not saying specifically ilamas
who am i talking about
small business owners put the money into
the guy that's creating a job and saying
government i don't need you i don't need
you to pay me for anything
let me go create a job you put the money
into the government the government's
going to say what we need more irs
agents
we need more this let me create a new
department give this money to this let
me do this research
and all of those researchers goes away
wasted and a billion dollars of tax
money went
nowhere and then you give to the people
you're just telling them
in about six months from now you're
gonna come back asking for more in about
six months from then you're going to
come back asking for more
i am turning you into a victim if i keep
giving you free money
if i keep giving you free money that's
what happens so going back to the
argument between these two guys
this is a philosophical debate i want to
tell you about a conversation i had
yesterday with dan price but i want to
first go to
tom because i think tom's got something
to share you know why
can't we just say bernie sanders you are
wrong
i mean people are afraid to say it he's
wrong i mean you keep jacking up taxes
like this
and that's your only agenda is to just
try to to squeeze the wealthy a little
bit more
san francisco is an unlivable city right
now
unlivable i mean if you were to go and i
have if you were to be in the city of
san francisco and see for your own eyes
what it's like you would not believe it
a few weeks ago i had to drive through
downtown l.a
to get to the children's hospital dash
was getting his uh his boot off his foot
after breaking his leg
and literally driving through downtown
you could
smell downtown l.a you could smell it
through closed windows
of your car it's really really bad in
some of these cities that believe
that taxing your way to solve every
problem is
the solution and and i just wish we
could maybe it'd be okay to say
hey bernie sanders you are wrong you
know or maybe just an objective person
to say
no you're incorrect same thing with dr
fausti i mean it's these guys that have
been in these positions for so long they
can get away with saying whatever they
want and we're supposed to take it for
gospel because one's a doctor one's a
senator
but you know and 185 billion that you're
talking about the irs would get in
newfound
where would that go i mean how long did
that even last that's more auditors
right
more government employees right but i
mean if and they said they'd find 185
billion dollars how long would that even
last in the treasury the other tax bill
that you have to watch is that one that
elizabeth warren and bernie want for the
uber wealthy yeah where they think they
can generate about three trillion over
the next 10 years
but they're coming after that money they
see it out there and they're oh it's
going to happen next year
listen it's going to happen next year
they by the way the reason why it's
going to happen next year they have to
do it pre-midterms
they have to do pre-midterms fyi if
i'm a democrat and i'm a democrat that i
have biden and kamal on my team
and i have to worry about keeping aoc
sanders happy
and elizabeth warren if you don't do the
tax plan next year
when can you do the tax plan let me say
this one more time if they don't
drive their tax plan next year what
happens
when's the next time they're going to
get an opportunity like that the year
after the midterm there's
no way they'll have that because they're
going to lose the house and they're
going to lose the senate right now it's
50 50.
all it takes is a couple and the house
is making some momentum
people typically get upset at midterms
and it flips it goes from all
you know typically you'll see a
republican have control of all three you
only have two years to impose your
philosophies
two years later you lose one of them
house or senate then you can't go as
aggressive
they're going to impose this in the next
12 months it'll most likely happen in
2022 when it happens
midterms they're going to say we told
you we were going to do this we did
then they'll all be united joe kamala
elizabeth warren sanders aoc all of
those guys from different camps
they'll be united going into 2024
because they want to continue this for
four more years
so that's what i see happening here and
that's one of the reasons so so remember
this here's a couple targets
uh florida major target for the state of
florida is going to be targeted hardcore
okay hardcore it's going to be targeted
desantis
public enemy number one right now number
two uh texas
is gonna get destroyed they're gonna be
hitting texas non-stop okay and by the
way texas is not as right-wing as people
think it is
texas is going more to the center and it
can be flipped just so everybody knows
they got people like beto over there
they got a lot of
superstars over there florida that's
coming up you know what's the next state
they're gonna
they're gonna target you're gonna see
tennessee being there you're gonna see
nevada being there
any of the states that are no state
taxes are number one enemy right now
because it's working
because it's working people are moving
there it's enemy the state number one
so you're gonna see a lot of articles
talking about terrible lifestyle
terrible living not the
funnest not this all these statistics
and research done by the government that
they get to control whatever kind of
data
that they want to control to sell their
points
the challenge with this is the following
yesterday i talked to dan price i don't
know if you remember dan price can you
pull up dan price
uh uh if you if you see who dan price is
if anyone's going to remember this guy i
think it's going to be you
uh uh pull up the article don't go
images i know this okay paid everybody
the same salary yeah paid everybody the
same salary so i got to tell you how
this thing went yesterday okay
just how this thing went yesterday fyi
if you guys didn't know this
when this guy did his news talking about
that he's lowering his income from 1.1
million to seventy thousand dollars
and he's gonna pay every single one of
his employees seventy thousand dollars
you ready what happened to that story
500 million
interactions on social media and
nbc's video becoming the most shared in
network
history besides from that it was the
most read article on new york times for
the week
front page of reddit two days in a row
front page of msnbc
front page of nbc front page of abc news
mashable
trending article on upworthy buzzfeed
trending on twitter for two days trended
on facebook for three days that story
what year was it 2015 when that came out
okay this is obama era
obama years prior to that gave him a
recognition as the entrepreneur of the
year
uh uh himself it was the sba
entrepreneur of the year award
presented to him by barack obama okay so
now watch what happened yesterday it's
very important to to hear the story
because
first of all i will plotted him to
coming on i told everybody i'm not sure
why this guy said yes
because i was surprised that he said yes
so i told him i said first of all kudos
to you for saying yes to this
and i said i appreciate you for doing
this because it's a case study for the
rest of us
rush limbaugh bashed this guy trashed
him he said he's going to go out of
business that's the ultimate socialistic
story
etc etc well fast forward to today
his business is doing 45 million dollars
a year and a net
four to five million dollars per year so
he's got a ten percent ebitda
what he's got four and a half million
dollar profits is a solid profits that
he's got
so we're talking yesterday and i said so
tell me how you're doing this he says
well you know i had an employee that was
making 35 000
i went outside i see him smoking
cigarettes he's stressed out he calls me
out he says oh you care about his money
and tell him look at all this we're not
making any money
and that hurt me for three days i
thought about it i came back i said
guess what i'm paying everybody seventy
thousand dollars
his executives were furious they left
that he had and he didn't have to take a
pay
of course they did everybody took a pay
cut his brother ended up suing him i
think in 2015 we didn't talk about it
yesterday
and uh you know this guy was a genius
christian guy who
memorized the bible in fifth and sixth
grade he would go to conce
contests grew up in a very conservative
family right so as we're going through
the conversation with them i asked him a
question i said let me ask you
so you ended up giving your seventy
thousand dollars income to everybody
including yourself he said yes
he hated peter thiel he called peter
thiel out nonstop
he was not a fan of elon musk a fan of
aoc a fan he called aoc the future
he was a fan of sanders a fan of sanders
and he was a fan of
not a fan of uh bezos i said what do you
think about biden give me one word that
you think about biden he said please
he says please like please i said what's
the one word you think about trump he
said who
so that's kind of where his position's
at right i said let me ask you a
question he says what's that
i said since you're doing four and a
half million dollar your inc four and a
half million dollars in net
i said you know if you wanted to sell
your company
in merchant account services you get 20
20 to 40 x
which means you're a 100 million dollar
guy he says he goes like this at first
right i said
what percentage of the company do you
own he says i own 100
i said i think that's unfair i said i
think you should i said how many
employees you get he said 200. i said i
think you should follow through
and give 200 of your employees each a
half a percent
because you're right now worth 100
million dollars then you backtrack well
it wouldn't work why wouldn't it work
well because of this this
because if we were to do it you know i
would never sell the company to anybody
because if somebody that bought the
company they would have to agree to pay
everybody seventy thousand dollars i've
never laid off anybody
i've never fired anybody and that just
wouldn't work because we're not a
hundred million dollar company i know
you're a hundred million dollar company
you got four and a half million dollars
of profits what do you guys do with the
profits well we talked about it
and then it led to the conversation
being
i said so let me get this straight you
call all these guys scam artist because
he says capitalism is a scam he says you
also bought into it he's telling me like
you also bought into this camp
it's a fascinating interview when this
thing comes out
i said so why wouldn't you give equity
to everybody he says there is no value
in the equity but you want 100
of it if it's 70 000 give it to
everybody i said what's wrong with the
way the system is in america the
capitalists can make money i don't mind
you being worth 100 million dollars
that's why i want you to follow through
he says well think about it it's a good
idea i'll think about it i said no
it's not fair you're worth 100 million
why not take that 100 million and share
it with everybody else everybody's worth
at least a half a million dollars
do that right so and then he started
talking all these rich people he called
that bezos he called that musk he called
out all these guys
who wishing to raise taxes like what do
we need to raise taxes to he says i'm
okay if we go to ninety percent i said
you wanna
he says we need to raise taxes on rich
people up to ninety percent i said what
country has it worked in america
we did it before and it worked that's
true i mean not that it worked no it's
true
it's true that it happened but it was
hollywood million dollar earners et
cetera et cetera in the
30s that's when communism was on the
uprise and they thought communism was
the way to go so
yes exactly so that was kind of hey
let's increase the taxes didn't work
it's not worked in any other country but
he's saying this i said can i ask you a
question
how much money you gave to charity last
year i'm not going to answer that
question for i said i'm just curious
because you sound so charitable how much
money did you give to charity last year
what's the point here bernie sanders is
telling others how to live
and go look at how much money he gives
away you tell me who's made a bigger
positive impact for the world between
the two
it's not even in one is creating the
other is regulating
let me get this straight one is creating
opportunities getting us to think
and find ways to improve the other one
is sitting out there saying
we gotta tax this guy more and slow him
down so if you and i
had a choice of having 10 bernie sanders
and 10 elon musks in the world
which one makes the world a better place
10 elon musk's or 10 bernie sanders i'm
curious not even a question
i'm curious what you think because your
argument is the fact that
one is talking about let's go on space
and the other one is talking about let's
fix the problem here
what would you say yeah i mean if it
clearly elon musk
why though tell me why jobs productivity
commerce i agree
but that's not at the same time bernie
sanders can have some valid points
it's not like it's it's a zero-sum game
where it's like
you either go elon or bernie do i agree
with taxing the wealthy and doing and
universal health care and all that
that bernie wants i don't agree with all
of that but do i agree that
income inequality is a problem do i
agree that
67 percent of americans live paycheck to
paycheck
and something needs to be done even
economics country in the world
and this has been almost 70 percent of
our people have paycheck to paycheck
but whose fault is that though we have
so much of like
here's the challenge man let me tell you
what the biggest challenge is with this
and it's it's very frustrating that we
have a hard time like
when i get a call and they tell me what
my son did wrong
okay like let's just say i get a call
from school and they tell me my son
they're wrong i got a great relation
with the school in
dallas prince of peace phenomenal shout
out to ms porter i trusted that woman a
lot
she did it the right way okay and we put
all our kids there private school
phenomenal place we had a great time
with them
when we left one of the biggest factors
that we didn't want to leave dallas was
the school
we loved the way they took care of our
kids at prince of peace and we're trying
to find something like that here
right but when i get a call and an email
will be sent
and the teacher would say here's how
your son reacted today he did this
this this that i said great so i'd get
on a call and i would notice this
teacher is reasonable she's got a good
point how do we work together
can you and then i would say you can
tell my son this you can tell my son
this you can tell my son this will work
and can you please give me feedback when
i come home home at night guess what i'm
going to talk to the guy
and i'd sit down he'd take her can i
talk to you hey dylan can i talk to you
hey senator can i talk to you and we
would work to do what
to have discourse to to to to improve to
sit down and figure out ways to improve
right and figure out a way on what we
can do to
make it a better place i don't mind the
criticism that we give to individuals
like elon musk
nothing wrong with that give it i have
no problem with that
but one is creating the other one is
regulating one is sitting there saying
how can we make something better
the other is sitting there saying how
can we slow this down one is saying
we kind of have to pay attention to
space on what's going on over there
because i don't know what's going to
happen over here
the other one is saying let's just fix
whatever we got going on today
one is thinking outside the box one just
wants to constantly
tax and regulate non-stop tax and
regulate non-stop
if we go into that direction it's going
to be very very problematic the
direction we're going right now so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you